- Elizabeth Holmes
aspired to be Steve Jobs,
but it turns out that she's
more like Bernie Madoff.
In 2003, a 19-year-old college dropout
named Elizabeth Holmes founded
a company called Theranos
that promised to
revolutionize blood testing.
She claimed to have invented a machine
that could run more than 200 tests
on just a few drops of blood
taken from a finger prick.
She wanted to sell diagnostic
tests directly to consumers.
Holmes was very persuasive.
She gave a TED Talk, where
she promoted Theranos
by calling it the most
disruptive technology
in the history of medicine.
- Yet, in the United States today,
healthcare is the leading
cause of bankruptcy,
and the lack of it the
leading cause of the suffering
associated with finding out too late
in the disease progression process
that someone you love
is really, really sick.
- Silicon Valley investors
treated her like a rockstar.
Walgreens quickly became
a corporate partner.
Major investors included Rupert
Murdoch, the Walton family,
and the family of former
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos.
Holmes' big promises attracted
some of the biggest names
in American government and foreign policy.
Bill Clinton was charmed by her,
and Joe Biden praised her efforts.
Secretaries of State Henry Kissinger
and George Shultz joined
the board of directors.
Former Secretaries of Defense James Mattis
and William Perry joined, too.
The company raised nearly
$1 billion in funding.
With the prospect of
eliminating many lab tests
and their associated costs,
there seemed to be
nothing stopping Theranos
from becoming a mega player
in the biotech industry.
Its highest valuation was
an eye-popping $9 billion.
But Walgreens, Murdoch, the US
foreign policy establishment,
and the other investors ignored
a very important principle
in investing and life.
If something seems too good to be true,
it probably is too good to be true.
(dramatic music)
As it turns out, there's
no way to run hundreds
of sophisticated diagnostic
tests on a few drops of blood.
Despite all the evidence that Holmes knew
her testing machine would never work,
a federal jury convicted her on just four
of the 11 charges against her,
three for wire fraud against investors,
and one for conspiracy to commit
wire fraud against investors.
One juror said it was
tough to convict her,
because, quote, "She was so likable.
"She had such a positive dream."
And it's a dream that they think
she honestly still believes in.
But as you can see,
there's probably a reason
why Jennifer Lawrence, Katie Holmes,
and Amanda Seyfried are all practicing
their most charming
and coldblooded stares.
So today, we're going to talk
about the Elizabeth Holmes trial.
Why did the jury find her guilty?
Why did they acquit her
on the other charges?
And how much did Holmes help herself
by testifying in her own defense?
So let's start with the
problems with Theranos,
which have been
well-chronicled at this point.
Blood analysis is one
of the most important
areas of medicine.
The two main players in the field,
Quest Diagnostics and Laboratory
Corporation of America,
generate over $75 billion
a year in revenue.
Theranos promised to upend this regime
by eliminating blood draws,
vials, large needles,
and lengthy waiting periods.
What if you could just go to
Walgreens, buy a testing kit,
and screen yourself for high cholesterol,
kidney disease, or even cancer?
Wouldn't that be great?
You'd save time, money,
get diagnosed faster,
and lives would be saved,
and that was the heart
of the Theranos project.
But there was just one
problem with this vision.
Most blood tests could not be done
with just a few drops of blood.
There aren't enough
molecules for detection.
One of Holmes' professors
had rejected her early ideas
for biotech companies on the basis
that the science and
technology could not exist.
The professor, Phyllis Gardner, later said
that she found the
conversations concerning,
because Holmes refused to accept
that some ideas were not possible.
She said, quote, "The hubris
of that just drove me insane."
But Holmes dropped out in
2004, and went on her own way,
aggressively selling
her ideas to investors.
Her company name Theranos is a combination
of therapy and diagnostics.
And while Holmes never
submitted any of her inventions
for any kind of peer
review, that didn't matter
to another Stanford
professor, Channing Robertson.
He said that the minute he heard her idea
about a diagnostic test from a pin prick,
he felt he was, quote,
"Looking into the eyes of
Steve Jobs, or Bill Gates."
Steve Jobs was, of course, the person
that many company founders
wanted to emulate.
Jobs created his own persona,
dressing only in black,
and promoting himself
as an eccentric genius.
Holmes took note of this,
and created her own mythos
that was trying to piggyback on Jobs.
She wore a black turtleneck
and black suit every day.
She had an intense stare
that became famous,
and we might laugh about this now,
but according to Tyler
Shultz, a Theranos employee,
investors like his
grandfather, George Shultz,
were mesmerized by this act.
But then came the whistleblowers.
In 2014, Tyler Shultz
emailed Holmes to complain
that Theranos had doctored research,
and ignored failed quality control checks.
Several other employees
had also raised concerns
about the company's science.
George Shultz was 95 at the time,
and Holmes called him
immediately to warn him
that she would get revenge on his grandson
if he took his complaints any further.
Tyler, though, anonymously contacted
New York State's Public Health Lab,
and filed a complaint alleging
that Theranos had manipulated
a process known as proficiency testing
relied on by federal and
state regulators to monitor
the accuracy of lab tests.
Theranos' lawyer, David Boies,
who later joined the board of directors,
surprised Tyler at his
grandfather's house,
informing him that the
company was suing him
for violating the terms of his NDA.
And while Tyler was the first
person to raise concerns
about Theranos to outside regulators,
he wouldn't be the last.
In 2015, "The Wall
Street Journal" published
a series of articles exposing
the Theranos testing machines as frauds.
By then, Holmes had been appointed
to the Harvard Medical Board
alongside her old
professor, Phyllis Gardner.
Gardner spoke with "The
Wall Street Journal"
about her belief that Holmes was a fraud,
and sure enough,
regulators soon discovered
that Holmes' Edison
machines frequently failed
quality control checks.
That means they produced
unreliable test results.
Theranos eventually told
regulators that it voided
all test results from Edison
machines for 2014 and 2015,
as well as some other tests
that ran on conventional machines.
The Edison machine
turned out to be a lemon.
Theranos claimed that its test
for one sexually transmitted
infectious disease was
sensitive enough to detect
the disease 95% of the time.
But when these results were
submitted for validation,
it showed sensitivities
of between 65% and 80%.
At the time, Walgreens was
partnering with Theranos
to provide in-store testing centers
at 40 Walgreens locations.
But when Walgreens realized
the scope of the problem,
they sued Theranos for $140 million.
Walgreens eventually
claimed that Theranos voided
11.3% of all blood test reports
that the company provided
to customers of Walgreens stores.
But instead of acknowledging the problems
with the Edison machine,
Theranos fabricated the results,
while continuing to market
the company to investors
as world-changing technology.
During the trial of Elizabeth Holmes,
prosecutors showed a presentation
that she had made to the
board of directors saying
that 10 of the 15 largest
pharmaceutical companies
in the world had validated
the Theranos results.
This was a lie.
The US Centers for Medicare
and Medicaid Services
investigated Theranos, and
banned Holmes from operating
a medical lab for two years.
The US Securities and Exchange Commission,
the SEC, charged Holmes
and former Theranos President
Sunny Balwani with fraud,
and barred Holmes from
serving as a director,
or officer of a public
company for a decade.
So that brings us to the
criminal case itself.
Holmes was indicted on 11
felony charges in 2018.
The charges included wire
fraud against investors,
wire fraud against
patients, and conspiracy.
And federal prosecutors
painted Holmes as a charlatan
who knew her technology didn't work.
They said she was obsessed
with fame and fortune,
and prosecutors presented evidence
that when Theranos
realized its test results
were not accurate, the
company substituted tests
from regular blood draws, making it look
as if the tests were
from blood droplet tests,
rather than traditional blood draws
and conventional machines.
But the strongest evidence showed
that Holmes exaggerated
the company's involvement
with potential partners.
Prosecutors demonstrated that Holmes lied
about having deals with drug companies
like Pfizer and the US military.
Holmes even added the logos of Pfizer
and Schering-Plough to lab reports
that she used in her
presentation to investors
and Walgreens executives.
But these companies
hadn't actually validated
any of Theranos' systems.
But the defense put on a case as well.
Holmes testified for seven days,
presenting herself as a visionary woman
in a male-dominated field.
Holmes told the jury
that she still believed
that Theranos was on the verge of proving
its technology worked.
She blamed her ex-partner, Sunny Balwani,
for misleading regulators about the tests.
Holmes told the jury that the two had
secretly lived together,
and that Balwani abused her
throughout the relationship,
and Balwani himself will go
on trial later this year.
And Holmes attempted to
raise a good faith defense
to the wire fraud charges.
Although good faith is
a defense to wire fraud,
an honest belief in the ultimate success
of the enterprise is
not in itself a defense,
and the judge instructed the
jury that if they believe
that she acted in good faith
in her representations,
then she could not also have acted
with an intent to defraud.
So let's dig into the
elements of wire fraud
and the conspiracy charges that she faced.
Holmes was eventually
convicted of three counts
of wire fraud and conspiracy
to commit wire fraud.
18 USC 1343 is the wire fraud statute.
It states, "Whoever, having
devised, or intending to devise,
"any scheme, or artifice to defraud,
"or for obtaining money, or
property by means of false,
"or fraudulent pretenses,
representations, or promises,
"transmits, or causes to be
transmitted by means of wire,
"radio, or television
communication in interstate,
"or foreign commerce, any
writings, signs, signals,"
yada, yada, "shall be
fined under this title,
"or imprisoned not more
than 20 years, or both."
So the prosecution had
to prove four elements,
first, that she knowingly participated
in some sort of scheme to
defraud and obtain money,
or property from other people.
Expressions of opinions,
aspirations, or goals,
or general subjective claims
can't be used as a basis
to find that someone made a false,
or fraudulent representation.
This is an important point,
and one we'll come back to when we talk
about the jury's conclusion
that she didn't defraud consumers,
probably because some jurors
said that she believed
that she had positive goals.
But the second prong is
that the statements made
as part of the scheme have to be material.
Statements tend to be material
if they have a natural
tendency to influence,
or are capable of influencing a person
to part with their money.
The third prong is that the
government needed to show
that Holmes acted with
the intent to defraud,
that is that she had
the intent to deceive,
and cheat someone out of
their money, or property.
And then the fourth
prong is that Holmes used
interstate wire communication to carry out
an essential part of the scheme.
And the jury found that
Holmes' misrepresentations
influenced investors to
send money to Theranos,
and that her presentations
actively intended
to defraud investors
by making them believe
that Theranos had big government contracts
and private partnerships
that would produce
a high rate of return on their investment.
And the jury also found
that Holmes had agreed
with other people to perpetrate
this scheme on others.
That's why she was convicted
of a conspiracy to commit
wire fraud as well.
The prosecution had lots of evidence
that Holmes concocted test
results to convince investors
that the science behind
her test was sound.
In a 2014 "Forbes" article,
Holmes said that Theranos,
quote, "Does not buy any
analyzers from third parties,"
and that was absolutely a lie.
Theranos presented results conducted
on these third-party analyzers
during their presentations to investors,
and it's highly likely
that the jury thought
that these lies were material,
and that they convinced investors
to part with their money.
And the three counts represented a total
of about $142 million in fraud.
But the jury deadlocked
on three additional
wire fraud counts related to investments
from three Theranos
investors, Alan Eisenman,
Chris Lucas of Black Diamond Ventures,
and Bryan Tolbert of the Hall Group.
Prosecutors now have to decide
whether they are going to retry her
on those three counts,
because the jury hung,
so they couldn't come to a decision
on those particular counts.
But Holmes and Balwani were also accused
of conspiring to commit wire fraud
in violation of 18 USC 1349.
The DOJ charged Balwani
and Holmes with making
materially false and misleading
statements to investors.
The government alleged
that the duo, quote,
"Made materially false
and misleading statements
"to investors and failed to
disclose material facts."
This included telling investors
that the company's proprietary
analyzer was accurate,
when in truth, it had
serious accuracy problems,
performed a limited number of tests,
was slower than some competing devices,
and could not compete with
larger conventional machines
in high-throughput, or the
simultaneous testing of blood
from many patients.
Holmes and Balwani
promised investors a return
on their investment in the
hundreds of millions of dollars,
while knowing that the
company would only gross
a few hundred thousand
dollars in 2014 and 2015.
Prosecutors proved that
Balwani and Holmes faked
test results during live
presentations for investors,
and the DOJ also said
that Holmes told investors
that the Walgreens partnership
would be expanding,
when in reality, Walgreens
was already moving
to end the partnership.
Balwani and Holmes told investors
that the Theranos technology
had already been deployed
by the US military on the
battlefield in Afghanistan,
which was untrue.
General Mattis testified
that they were not being used
by the military.
When the jurors spoke
out after the verdict,
two of them said that
the jury ranked witnesses
according to their believability,
and that they rated Mattis as the witness
with the highest
credibility, not surprising.
Mattis said that he wanted the
military to do a test program
with Theranos analyzers, but
the tests never happened.
Balwani and Holmes told investors
that they didn't need FDA
approval for the machines
and tests when they already
knew that they needed clearance
from the FDA.
And the two also allegedly
lied to the media,
and then used the articles
and news segments containing
their lies to promote
Theranos to investors.
And to find Holmes guilty
of the conspiracy charges,
the jury had to believe
that she hatched a plan
to commit wire fraud in partnership
with Balwani, or others.
If the jurors thought that she
just went along with Balwani
because of their partnership,
that probably wouldn't have risen
to the level of conspiracy.
But what about the other charges of fraud
for crimes perpetrated against patients?
The jury actually acquitted
Holmes of wire fraud
and conspiracy to defraud patients.
So let's talk about why
that likely happened.
During the four-month trial,
the prosecution devoted
very little time to proving
this part of the case.
The patients who purchased
Theranos tests only testified
for about one hour in total.
The government accused Holmes
and Theranos of making
material misrepresentations
about its Edison machine
in advertisements.
The ads mostly targeted physicians.
The prosecution argued
that these ads induced
hundreds of patients to
pay Theranos, or Walgreens,
for blood tests and test results,
which obviously wouldn't have worked.
The government said Balwani
and Holmes told doctors
and patients that Theranos
could provide accurate, fast,
reliable, and cheap blood
tests and test results,
but they already knew that
Theranos technology was
in fact not capable of
consistently producing accurate
and reliable results.
This was the alleged wire fraud,
because Theranos used
interstate electronic wires
to purchase advertisements intending
to induce individuals to
buy the tests in Walgreens,
and stores in California and Arizona.
And the prosecution had
evidence that Theranos placed
advertisements in Walgreens and on TV
with their total marketing
effort slightly over $1 million.
But at the same time, the
prosecutors didn't have
the same kinds of direct communications
between Holmes and individual patients
as they did between Holmes and investors.
And theoretically, patients
only used Theranos tests
because they were referred
by their physicians.
So it's possible the
jury might have believed
that there were too many
intermediaries between Holmes
and the individual patients
and doctors to conclude that
Holmes actually influenced
the patients themselves.
And the defense argued that
the prosecution needed to show
that Holmes really intended
to defraud these patients.
Arguably, her company gave
patients inaccurate test results,
but inaccurate test results
alone don't necessarily meet
the criteria for an intent to defraud.
The prosecutors needed to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that Holmes knowingly
participated in, devised,
or intended to devise a plan
to defraud these patients.
And as we talked about earlier,
generally, opinions, aspirations, goals,
or subjective beliefs can't
be used as a basis to find
that someone made a false,
or fraudulent representation.
And the jurors who spoke
out after the verdict said
that they believed Holmes when she said
she never intended to defraud patients.
And juror number six, Wayne
Katz, an Emmy-winning TV writer
for a 1990s show called
"Tiny Toon Adventures,"
was inspired by Holmes' testimony.
Quote, "We respected Elizabeth's
belief in her technology,
"in her dream.
"We thought, 'She still believes in it,
"'and we still believe
she believes in it.'"
He's saying that she
had a subjective belief,
even to this day, that she
was helping her patients,
not hurting them.
Katz said that the jury quickly
decided to acquit Holmes
on all four counts of
fraud against patients.
The jury thought Holmes
was one step removed
from the patients, so that they
were not directly defrauded.
Of course, this was also
somewhat contradictory,
since Katz also opined that
everything ran through Holmes.
But this is just what
you often get from jurors
who are grappling with
difficult questions of law.
Mike Kew, juror number 11, said
that although the panel thought
Holmes' credibility was low,
they also believed that she was genuine.
But what happens next?
Each of the four counts that
Holmes was convicted of carries
a maximum sentence of 20 years in prison.
So theoretically, she could
get 80 years in prison,
but this will be reduced
and modified by the federal
sentencing guidelines.
Several former prosecutors think
she'll probably get less
than 20 years in prison,
especially as a first-time offender,
and the high-profile nature of the case
and the scope of the
fraud probably suggest
that she won't exactly get
a slap on the wrist, though.
That's because the federal
sentencing guidelines require
the judge to consider
the magnitude of the lies
and how much money the investors lost,
and the fact that she was CEO.
In these kinds of white collar crimes,
the more money that is pilfered,
the more prison you could get,
and $140 million is quite a lot,
though Holmes may be
able to sway the judge
for less prison time by
pointing to her relative youth,
her capacity for change,
and the allegations of abuse
at the hands of Balwani,
and there will almost
certainly be a very hefty fine.
The government can retry her
on the other wire fraud charges,
but that seems unlikely.
The government has already
spent significant resources
and time on the case,
and they got a conviction
on four counts carrying
a serious prison sentence.
So that may be enough,
particularly in light
of the upcoming Balwani trial,
which is also probably going
to be an expensive prosecution.
So it turns out that Theranos was a fraud
and a terrible investment.
But you can avoid terrible investments
and start investing for your goals
with today's sponsor, Wealthfront.
Wealthfront is an automated
investment platform
that uses software to
find the optimal portfolio
to grow your money long-term
based on your risk tolerance.
When you're young, you have
decades of compound interest
to use to your advantage,
meaning that over time,
your money can make you more money,
which then makes you more money,
and that makes you even more money.
And there's decades of
data out there showing
that investing in a globally
diversified portfolio
of low-cost index funds
is one of the best ways
to put your savings to work,
and Wealthfront makes that
process easy, accessible,
and affordable, no matter what
your knowledge, or finances.
Their account setup is
also incredibly simple.
You just need a few minutes
and $500 to open an investment account,
and they will take care of the rest.
They also automatically
use a strategy called
tax-loss harvesting that could
lower the taxes that you pay
without any additional work on your end.
And best of all, they've agreed to waive
their already tiny .25% management fee
up to the first $5,000 invested
for the rest of your life,
not to mention they also
give you free access
to their financial planning tools,
which allow you to estimate
your net worth over time,
and estimates how you can further save
and invest more money based
on your income and spending.
So all you have to do to
try out Wealthfront is click
on the link that's on screen right now,
or in the description.
And again, to start investing today
and get Wealthfront to waive
their annual management fee
up to the first $5,000
for the rest of your life,
click on the link that's on screen.
And while you're there, click on this link
for more "Real Law Reviews,"
or I'll see you in court.